Bob so much to talk about you covered
what many people call the most exciting
Super Bowl was one of them
memory one of them yep absolutely
stunning you were there what were you
thinking in that final play the Seahawks
what how far were they from a yard a
yard a yard with Marshawn Lynch having
gained four yards on first down
they've got three plays left and a
timeout yes and Marshawn Lynch in a
situation like that you could take the
whole offensive line away and just put
12 before 11 defenders against him and
he would probably drag all of them
through the back of the end zone and to
the concession stand yes and so you say
to yourself why not just hand it to
Marshawn Lynch it looked like they were
definitely going to score on that drive
it was inevitable it did and you as a
patriot fan know that at that point they
would have been three and three and
there's six Super Bowls yep and the
three defeats all would have been
because of absurd impossible yeah
patches yes but they lucked out this
time so what do you think how did you
react yourself when they decided to to
put the ball in the air and it was
accepted I was surprised and it's such a
good story you know this kid Malcolm
Butler first interception of his career
from West Alabama first player from West
Alabama division to school to ever play
in a Super Bowl five years ago no joke
he's working at a Popeye's Chicken
he's an undrafted free agent alright and
he picks off Russell Wilson and wins the
Super Bowl he single-handedly wins the
Super Bowl and you're saying that he
basically as would be the least likely
candidate to do it except for a guy
named Chris Matthews who almost played a
similar role for Seattle had not caught
a single pass all season long caught
four passes including a touchdown pass
with two seconds to go in the first half
of the game last night to tie it up and
what I'm thinking Al Michaels is calling
the game and nobody's better than Al and
Chris at calling a game but then I'm
gonna kind of sum it up and talk to
right some of the experts and you're
trying to think what's gonna be the big
storyline here
but the storyline changes like that yeah
the story lines gonna be Seattle is won
back-to-back championships they've got a
mini dynasty and they've denied the
Patriots their spot in the pantheon of
great teams they're still in there
somewhere but they're no longer at the
very very top and then in two seconds
the whole thing changes the whole story
changes okay you just said it Patriots
greatest of all time that's all I need
you to say yeah you know you can go now
no but I'm but do you really think I
mean let's talk about Belichick and
Brady do you think as a duo they might
be because people will always debate it
with the great teams and clearly now the
Patriots will be up there because they
have these Super Bowl wins but and and
they've been in six but what is it about
Brady and Belichick in your opinion do
they have some kind of is there some
sort of weird kismet between them what
yeah they're there obviously is some
understanding they're different kinds of
personalities but they mesh well
together bill walsh won three Super
Bowls and never lost one with Joe
Montana but then bill burned out he said
it himself stepped aside George Seifert
the guy who replaced him who won another
one with Montana and then one more with
Steve Young who knows how many bill
walsh would have won Chuck Noll won four
in a shorter period of time
with Terry Bradshaw but only Belichick
and Brady together got to 6 yeah they
got to 6 they won four and the two they
lost they lost by the narrowest and
strangest of margins so you know I don't
know that you can say definitely they're
the best ever
but I can't put anybody ahead of them
you